president trump accepts the republican
nomination from the white house as
protesters get rowdy outside
kamala harris claims black lives aren't
taken seriously in the united states
and the republican national convention
wraps up i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn your data is your business
protected at expressvpn.com
ben well before we get to everything
else let me just announce to you that my
sleep lately it has been disturbed by my
small child i have a very small child
who's six months old and she's not yet
sleep trained and that means i treasure
the moments between the times when she
is waking up and bothering us in the
middle of the night because i'm on that
helix sleep mattress it's a helix sleep
mattress made
just for me helix sleep has a quiz it
takes just two minutes to complete
matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you
whether you're a side sleeper or hot
sleeper whether like a plush or from bed
with helix there's no more confusion
no more compromising helix sleep is
rated the number one mattress by gq and
wired magazine
cnn called it the most comfortable
mattress they've ever slept on all you
have to do is head on over to
helixsleep.com
take that two minute sleep quiz they
will match you to a customized mattress
that'll give you the best sleep
of your life it's excellent okay i have
a helix sleep mattress again
i value it greatly at this time not only
because hardestly generally but also
because i got a kid waking me up in the
middle of the night so
in those moments when i'm not awakened
by my child i need a personalized
mattress helix is offering up to 200
bucks off all
mattress orders for our listeners get up
to 200 bucks off at helix sleep dot com
slash ben again that's helixsleep.com go
check them out helixsleep.com for up to
two
hundred dollars off a mattress that is
custom made just for you check them out
right now helix sleep.com
slash ben alrighty so we'll get to the
republican national convention last
night but let's just be clear about this
the people who are currently making the
case for president trump to be president
are not republicans
they are all of the rioters and the
looters and the violent jackasses in the
streets
harassing normal people who are not
bothering anybody
who are attempting to do violence or who
are being terrible human beings
it is also the politicians on the
democratic side of the aisle who have
decided to soft pedal all of this
who've decided that they are going to
look over they're just going to say
you know we understand their motivation
we understand what they're doing we get
it we do
you know it's kind of unnecessary but
really america is systemically racist
really
their cause is just america really is a
terrible
no good very bad place the democrats who
are willing to overlook simple fact
patterns
in particular cases in order to draw a
broad overarching narrative about how
america is systemically terrible
this is what is driving trump's reelect
prospects at this point in time
all the democrats had to do and i've
been saying this since the day that
trump was elected
all they had to do was not be crazy and
they just couldn't do it
they tried for a brief second in time to
nominate somebody who was not the crazy
person right
they nominated joe biden in order to not
nominate the octogenarian communist
and it turns out that joe biden is too
weak to stand up to his own base
he is too weak to stand up to the
radicalism inherent in his own party and
the fact is that even
the administration he last served under
was rather radical on a lot of these
matters remember there were cities that
burned during the last democratic
administration
ferguson burned while barack obama stood
there and said that people don't make up
things
like what happened with michael brown
except that everything that was said
about michael brown was in fact made up
by witnesses who lied about it at the
time ferguson byrne
baltimore burned while barack obama was
president of the united states
again based on a case where the officers
were found not to have committed a
murder
new york city was pro massive protest in
new york city while barack obama
milwaukee
burned while barack obama was president
so it's not as though democrats haven't
presided over this sort of stuff in the
past and it is democratic cities that
are currently burning
it is democratic mayors who have allowed
this to go on as i mentioned yesterday
this really is not all that difficult
government has one job
one job protect your rights and the
minute that you say that the cops have
to be pulled out of areas
where they are protecting law-abiding
citizens from criminals and villains
the minute you say that the cops are the
bad guys and the criminals and the
villains are the good guys
you have lost the thread well the
democrats have lost the threat
and not only have they lost the threat
they've decided to reject reality
they like completely reject it reality
is no longer of consequence
in too many parts of the democratic
party and this is how you end up with
the notion
in the democratic party that facts are
secondary to narrative
so there's more information now coming
out on the shooting of jacob blake in
kenosha wisconsin which has led to these
massive riots in kenosha wisconsin
burning down of
city blocks right while the democrats
said nothing about it all of last week
for the democrats it was all about
america being systemically racist and
evil and terrible and no good and very
bad
but no real harsh words for the rioters
and the looters even joe biden's tempted
little statements about how it's
unnecessary violence it's unnecessary
why is it unnecessary according to joe
biden it's unnecessary because well you
know you can use the political process
to elect people like joe biden
but if donald trump would win again then
the threat of fascism is on the horizon
in which case presumably it's necessary
there's a rather open extortion tactic
that is being used by democrats
these days that is extraordinarily ugly
i i've yet to see a republican riot
okay like in the modern era have you
seen republicans rioting i'm old enough
to remember when they were calling tea
partiers terrorists
we're standing there with american flags
and playing corny songs
and wearing hats with the brims not
properly bent
right that they were terrorists the tea
party were bad guys
not one incident of serious violence at
a tea party protest
not one okay now you have nearly every
blm protest breaking out randomly
apparently
into some sort of riot or looting as
soon as the curfew hits
and yet we are being told that these are
the best among us this is this is the
kind of protest that america stands for
but you know what
you really shouldn't get too violent
because after all you can just elect joe
biden this octogenarian
50-year politician who's not
accomplished anything of major
consequence in his career except for the
only thing that he actually did was a
a criminal a criminal justice bill that
lengthened sentences that he now says
was a bad idea
so all of this has come to a head in the
last week and a half
you can see the shift in the narrative
because democrats are starting to
realize that this is extraordinarily
damaging like seriously seriously
damaging to their electoral prospects
in wisconsin particularly rural
wisconsin is going to show up and vote
now
rural minnesota and minneapolis are
going to show up and vote now there are
a lot of people who weren't going to
show up and vote because they were
alienated by trump's personality and the
dnc banked on people being alienated by
trump's personality
that was the dnc's entire pitch there
was nothing there about what they were
actively going to do
they ignored their own agenda it was all
about how trump was a bad mean orange
bad man well guess what
trump can be a bad orange mean bad
orange man but when people are watching
cities burn
and when they are watching suburbs being
invaded
by rioters and looters and we saw that
in seattle last night
when they see people walking through the
streets of major cities
and being harassed and harangued by
protesters getting directly in their
face
when they're watching people being
punched in the head for no reason other
than their political perspective
when they see that they go okay so
you're you're telling me that because
trump
is vulgar and a boor and because he does
things i don't like
then i'm supposed to vote for people who
incentivize this this sort of extortion
americans resent being extorted they
resent the electoral
extortion that is now being effectuated
upon them by the democratic party
and again the democratic party is going
full scale with this sort of stuff they
really are they are ignoring fact
patterns in order to propagate a
narrative they think will be electorally
valuable for them that will drive out
what they think will be minority voters
to the polls i think it's going to
backfire in a pretty significant way
here
they're ignoring fact patterns there's
new information on the jacob lake
shooting as i mentioned
here's the new information this is
according to the wisconsin doj
investigation
quote after the initial attempt to
arrest mr blake kenosha police officer
rustin chesky deployed a taser to
attempt to stop mr blake when that
attempt failed kenosha police officer
vincent tarinis also deployed a taser
however that taser was also not
successful in stopping mr blake
also blake admitted he had a knife in
his possession
on the tape by the way one of the cops
can be heard shouting drop the knife
okay but apparently fact patterns don't
matter they literally don't matter we've
been told by top-level democrats that
the facts of these cases
do not matter because the overarching
narrative is all that matters
and when you ignore the facts in order
to preserve an overarching narrative
that ends with riots and looting
when you soft-peddle the riots in the
looting americans are going to resent it
for example here's wisconsin's
lieutenant governor yesterday he
literally said we don't need an
investigation
into this case this is lieutenant
governor mandela barnes democrat of
wisconsin
he literally says in a case that
requires an investigation we don't need
an investigation now first of all i
think the fact on the ground and the
tape on the ground already show
that any investigation is going to end
with the acquittal of these cops that
there are no criminal charges that will
be
they cannot be you can't file criminal
charges against police officers who
arrive to arrest a man
with an open warrant for domestic abuse
and sexual assault
and by the way we are now learning that
one of the people that the person who
called the cops
was apparently one of his prior victims
okay and he showed up at her house
and that's why she called the cops the
cops show up he resists arrest he has
tased twice he ignores their orders he
gets up
he may or may not have a knife we don't
know that yet we do know that he reaches
into the car and they find on the
floorboards of the driver's side
a knife okay i am sorry there is no
circumstance whatsoever under which
these cops are convicted
of anything it's just not going to
happen but according to the democrats
not only should these cops be convicted
you don't even need an investigation the
facts literally don't matter here's the
lieutenant governor of the state of
wisconsin claiming
that we don't need an investigation to
determine that this was not only a bad
shooting but a racial shooting so they
haven't established that it's bad
they haven't even established that it's
racially motivated they haven't
established one iota of this stuff
all that matters is the overarching
narrative as long as democrats propagate
this stuff and then riots break out in
the streets and they poo poo it
americans are not going to vote for this
they are not
okay here is lieutenant governor
mantella barnes as the governor said
dci's investigation is ongoing but we
don't need an investigation to know
that blake's shooting falls in a long
and painful pattern
of violence and this is a pattern of
violence that happens
uh against black lives too often across
this country
and as you all know we saw even more gun
violence unfold on tuesday night
when two protesters were tragically
killed and one other injured
by gunshots okay we don't need an
investigation and
i'm going to give you the exact reverse
of what happened okay
when it comes to the quote-unquote
protesters who were shot and killed the
tape
shows them attacking the person who did
the shooting it's all on tape guys
and we don't need an investigation by
the way we don't need an investigation
is the mark of people who don't give a
damn about due process
it turns out due process is one of the
core protections of the bill of rights
and one of the core reasons for
government to exist
and there's the lieutenant governor
saying we don't need an investigation to
already determine
how this fits into our pre-existing
narrative about black people inherently
being victims in the united states
incredible in a second we're going to
see the vice presidential candidate on
the democratic side say exactly the same
thing we'll get to that in just one
moment first
let us talk about the fact that hiring
on your own without any assistance it
can be really really
difficult like very very difficult it's
really important that you have somebody
to help you go through that process
zipper crew is the best way to do it
zip recruiter will send your job to over
100 of the web's leading
job sites but they don't stop there with
their powerful matching technology
zip recruiter will scan thousands of
resumes to find people with the right
experience
and actively invite them to apply to
your job zip recruiter makes the entire
hiring process efficient and effective
with features like screening questions
to filter candidates and an all-in-one
dashboard where you can review
and rate your candidates ziprecruiter is
so effective that four out of five
employers who post on zip recruiter get
a quality candidate within
the very first day so let's say the day
after day after day
your producer let's call him colton for
example he suggests guests they're just
like why would you possibly suggest that
this person would make a good guess
why and let's say you decide to book
somebody else who'll be better at
booking guests like a one-armed monkey
or something
but you can't find a one-armed monkey so
where do you go you go to
ziprecruiter.com right now to try zip
recruiter for free
my listeners can go to ziprecruiter.com
dailywire that is ziprecruiter.com
d-a-i-l-y-w-i-r-e ziprecruiter.com
daily wire zip recruiter is indeed the
smartest way to hire ziprecruiter.com
alrighty so it was not just the
wisconsin
lieutenant governor who says who says we
don't need an investigation it was
kamala harris
your former prosecutor right now it
seems to me that if you're a former
prosecutor you should be responsible
enough to say
you know we might need an investigation
before we prosecute somebody but kamala
harris
let's throw them all in jail kamala
harris she says we don't need
an investigation we should just charge
the officer in the jacob lake case
we should just charge him no
investigation necessary now let me just
take it with a grain of salt
because kamala harris is an awful human
being who literally has suggested
that cops murder people when the murder
not only has been
investigated but debunked she literally
tweeted out last year that michael brown
was murdered michael brown the 18 year
old
who attacked a police officer reached
into his car fired the police officer's
gun
tried to run away turned around and
charged the police officer and was shot
for his trouble
that is according to two separate state
prosecutors
that is according to the obama
department of justice kamala said he was
murdered
so here's kamala harris ignoring the
requirements of due process
ignoring the notions of individual
justice ignoring the belief that facts
matter
in order to preserve the narrative the
black people are inherently put under
the knife
in the united states of america circuits
2020. and this is the
and then you expect people not to write
you expect people not to loot
here's kamala harris doing this routine
is there a scenario in which that
officer
would have been justified was justified
in firing his weapon
craig i don't i don't see it but i don't
have all the evidence
you know the man was was going to his
car he didn't appear to be armed
and if he was not armed the use of force
that was seven bullets coming out of a
gun at close range in the back
of the man i don't see how anybody could
reason that that was justifiable do you
think the officer should be charged
i think that there should be a thorough
investigation
and based on what i've seen it it seems
that the officer should be charged
oh well so there should be a full
investigation but also he should be
charged
which means you don't need the
investigation do you she could just say
there needs to be a thorough
investigation that could be the end of
the sentence
could it not there needs to be a
thorough investigation but we've already
been told by the lieutenant governor of
wisconsin you don't need an
investigation to determine what happened
and there's kamala harris suggesting we
need a thorough investigation i don't
see a circumstance
by the way we already know there was a
knife on the floorboard of the car we
already know that is the case on the
driver's side okay it's not all the way
in the back it wasn't in the trunk or
something we know there's a man with an
open warrant
for sexual assault and domestic abuse
with three kids in the back of the car
he has resisted arrest he's been tased
twice
he walks away from the police officers
after bucking them off his back
and the idea is what the cops are
supposed to let him go with three kids
in the back of the car
but don't worry kamala harris has it all
covered has it all covered now here's
the thing
democrats don't have to do this they
don't have to soft-pedal the violence
but they do because they're enthralled
to their woke base
and the woke base is not in fact black
americans
the woke base is not black see this is
the great misnomer is that if you keep
saying stuff like this you're gonna
drive black voters to the polls on mass
you're gonna get the obama coalition of
2008 back together
when democrats refuse to condemn the
violence in the streets when democrats
soft pedal it when they say things not
like
it is more it's a moral blight what is
happening right now it is vicious and
evil what is happening right now
when they refuse to condemn this in
stark terms when instead they say things
like well it's unnecessary or we condemn
violence on all sides right
i'm old enough to remember by the way
when it was considered insufficient
rightly
for the president of the united states
to say about charlottesville
that there were bad people on many sides
there were bad things happening on many
sides on many sides that was his
original statement it drove a lot of ire
including from me go back and listen to
my podcast that day
joe biden is saying exactly the same
thing now he refuses to condemn
the violence and the looting that is
springing directly from black lives
matter protests
he's refusing to the democrats are
refusing to you know why
it ain't it is not because they are
enthralled to
to black americans it is because they
are enthralled to white woke liberals
who feel
more virtuous by condemning the united
states by dissociating
from the history culture and philosophy
of the united states of america they
don't have to do this you know how i
know they don't have to do this
because there's a courageous man his
name is representative john de berry
he's a democrat from tennessee
and a few days ago he made a speech and
his speech he talked about
how he had grown up in jim crow america
and how the rioters and the violent
looters
and all of these garbage human beings
are in fact garbage human beings
and he named it and he shamed it in
stark terms he is a democrat
he is a black democrat by the way the
notion that black americans
are desperately in favor of people
rioting and looting and burning down
largely black communities by the way
is insane the democrats have decided to
rally around this flag because here is
the problem
there are three visions of the united
states that are currently on the table
vision number one the united states is
an incredible place
with an incredible founding philosophy
we have not always lived up to that
founding philosophy but working within
the system of that philosophy and within
the constitutional system we can
effectuate change that reaches toward
the perfection
of the ideals of the declaration of
independence right that is one vision of
the country
in my book how to destroy america in
three easy steps i turn this the
unionist vision for the country
then there's the disintegrationist
vision of the country the
disintegrationist vision of the country
says america is steeped and rooted in
evil
the founding principles are wrong they
were a lie when written as the 1619
project says
and they remain a lie today they were
but pretty words
slathered atop a base of racism and
white supremacy
and that we need to destroy the system
from within this is the ibram x kendi
anti-racist notion that in order to be
anti-racist you have to destroy the
entire system
the democratic party wants it both ways
so the democratic party wants to argue
along with the
disintegrationists that america is
indeed
rooted in foundational racism bigotry
homophobia sexism and all the rest
just like aoc says but we should also
work within the system
the problem is that once you have
granted the premise to this
to disintegrationists who wish to
effectuate violent means then you're
just arguing over means you're not
arguing over core philosophy
now the democrats many of them would
like you to believe that they actually
agree with the unionist vision
that america's founding philosophy is
good that you can work within the system
but then they refuse to condemn the
violence because in essence
meant too many of them agree with the
fundamental premise of the rioters and
looters which is that america is so evil
thoroughly rotten stem to stern they
just gotta blow up the boat it's the
only way
so if you're just arguing whether to
blow up the boat or whether you should
put us in charge of the boat
that's gonna be a difficult case to make
and that is why you're seeing democrats
be so ginger about all this now again
you don't have to do this if you
actually believe in the country
in a second i'm gonna show you a
democrat who believes in the country a
black democrat from tennessee
who believes in the country enough to
condemn what's going on meanwhile joe
biden won't we'll get to that in one
second first
let's talk about a truly meaningful gift
that you can give to somebody you care
about or to yourself
i am talking about paintyourlife.com
you can choose from a team of
world-class artists and work with them
until every detail
is perfect here's how it works you get a
hand-painted portrait in about
three weeks you send any picture
yourself your kids family a special
place cherished pet
you can combine photos in one painting
and then you choose the artist
and then they will help you along with
the process i've done it myself they
send you updates
you can make changes to it and by the
way
it's guaranteed because if you don't
love the final painting your money is
refunded so
sitting above our mantelpiece in our in
our main room right now
is a giant painting from paint your life
of me and my wife and two of our three
children so it's about time to update
that since we have a tiny little one
who's extraordinarily cute
so we're gonna head back to
paintyourlife.com at painterlife.com
again there's no risk if you don't love
the final painting your money is
refunded guaranteed
right now it's a limited time offer you
get twenty percent off your painting
that is correct twenty percent off plus
free shipping
to get the special offer text the word
ben to sixty four thousand that is ben
to sixty four thousand again text the
word ben to sixty four thousand paint
your life
celebrate the moments that matter most
really amazing gift
paintyourlife.com and again use that
code ben to get 20
off okay so democrats are fully capable
of condemning this stuff
here's representative john jay de berry
jr democrat from memphis
from the state legislature this is from
august 12th talking about the violence
my family raised money and sent my dad
to washington for that march
well that man stood there and said that
he wanted his
children judged by the content
of their character not the color of
their skin
and all we do in america right now is
talk about
color every issue every issue is about
race it's about
color instead of us sitting down at the
table
like men and women of common sense and
common justice
and understanding that our enemies are
looking with a greedy vigilance upon
us as we tear ourselves
apart eternally peaceful protest
ends peacefully anarchy
ends in chaos and what we see
happening right now any of us with any
common sense
any common sense whatsoever know that
what we see
is not peaceful by the way he was a
democrat
i should correct this the democratic
party ousted him i'm not kidding
okay so what he is saying here is is
what every democrat should be saying
now he has been i'm not kidding he has
been ousted
from the by the tennessee democratic
party's executive committee
he now has to run as an independent
because he has conservative positions on
issues like abortion and school choice
okay but there is a man who lived under
segregation in jim crow pointing out
that doing violence doing evil is in
fact evil will the democrats take them
up on this
no of course the democrats won't take
him up on this instead you'll get
milk toast tepid statements from joe
biden so yesterday joe biden he said
i can done violence in all forms in all
forms in all forms in all forms
weird because i remember when donald
trump said the same thing about the
charlottesville
situation the charlottesville standoff
between antifa and the alt-right white
supremacists
he was widely condemned as he should
have been because he was not specific
enough about the
source of the original violence namely
the alt-right or the perspective of the
alt-right
here was joe biden doing the yes i
condem violence on all sides on all
sides on all sides
by the way i condemn violence in any
form
whether it's looting or whatever it is
and by the way when i spoke to
when i spoke to the family the mom was
really incredibly straightforward she
said
this is not who we are as a family this
is not who my son
is we condemn the violence and so who's
who's
rooting for the violence here who's
rooting for the we condemn the violence
i mean we condemn it i mean it's bad i
mean like the violence is bad
but also but also jacob blake had made
me sick to my stomach what i saw on that
tape
black man being shot down in in d in
broad daylight is what he said the day
before
and then joe biden tries to make the
case that this is trump's america and he
wants more riots
that trump wants more riots they want
the entire dnc eight hours in prime time
without mentioning riots and looting
eight hours and then joe biden's like
well this is trump's america
okay no you don't get to play that game
because when trump sent federal forces
into portland to try and put this stuff
down
you call them a fascist when trump
offered 500 extra national guard troops
to governor tony evers in wisconsin
evers turned him down
you don't get to play this game or when
trump tries to stop the violence you
call him a fascist
and then you suggest that he actually
wants the violence while you yourself
continue to
issue milk toast statements about how
you condemn all violence all violence is
very bad
i mean sure black people are being shot
down by the cops at an exorbitant
rate and america's systemically racist
and evil but riots and looting i mean
they're unnecessary
unnecessary i i struggle to think if he
believes that
when is violence necessary says if you
believe that america is such a place
where black people are under daily
threat
from the establishment system when would
violence become necessary in joe biden's
view
here was joe biden trying to blame all
of this on trump and by the way making a
soft extortion case in the process
you'll hear him say here that um all of
this will go away if he's elected
so in other words just get rid of donald
trump and all this goes away nice
country you got there would be a shame
if somebody did something to it
here's joe biden the problem we have
right now
is we're in donald trump's america you
know to uh
to quote kelly conway she said and i'm
paraphrasing today that
they're looking for more violence and
more disruption because it helps them
politically
he views this as a political benefit to
him you know
he's rooting uh for more violence not
less and it's clear about that and
what's he doing
he's kept pouring gasoline on the fire
this happens to be donald
trump's america and someone trumps
america and then he says and if you get
rid of donald trump it'll all stop weird
because again cities burned under joe
biden
the tacit threat here at cities will
continue to burn the protest i mean
literally last week kamal o'hara said
the protests are necessary and they
should continue
they should continue don't worry no
rioting and looting guys all the
figments of your imagination
it's starting to come home because the
polls are showing that americans don't
like this stuff
and so now democrats are swiveling on
time and being oh yeah i guess we
probably should
do something about it maybe a little bit
but they're still incentivizing
the riots and the looting they're still
giving credence to the main case which
is that america is broadly and
systemically evil and racist
we'll hear kamala harris make that case
a an extraordinarily
wealthy privileged black woman in the
united states of america make the case
that america literally does not care
about black people
in just one second first let's talk
about the fact that
now is not a great time to go to the
post office you know what it is a great
time to do it's a great time to
use the postal service without having to
go to the post office and that means
using stamps.com we here at the
dailywire we've been using stamps.com
since 2017 to save time and save money
thousands of small business owners have
discovered the benefits of stamps.com
in recent months with stamps.com you can
print postage on demand you can avoid
going to the post office
you'll save money with discounted rates
you can't even get at the post office
stamps.com also offers ups services with
discounts up to 62
no residential surcharges stamps.com
will bring all the mailing and shipping
services you need right to your computer
in the comfort of your home or office
whether you're a small business and
sending invoices or an online seller
shipping out products
or just working from home and you need
to mail stuff stamps.com can handle it
all
with ease simply use your computer to
print official us postage 24 7 for any
letter any package any class of mail
anywhere you want to send it once your
mail is ready just leave it for your
mail carrier schedule a pickup or drop
it in a mailbox it is indeed that simple
as i've said with sams.com you get great
discounts as well 5 cents off every
stamp up to 62
off usps and ups shipping rates which
means that stamps.com is a no-brainer it
saves you time and it saves you money
right now my listeners get a special
offer it includes a four-week trial plus
free postage and
digital scale no long-term commitment
just head on over to stamps.com click on
the microphone at the top of the home
page
type in shapiro that is stamps.com enter
shapiro
right now okay so as the democrats
softly claim that they're not in favor
of the violence and the protests and
and the looting and all this sort of
stuff well they they they try to
separate off the protests from the
violence but as soon as you condemn the
violence they say you're condemning the
protest this is the little
is that a little game a little martin
bailey game well kamala harris continues
to make the case
that black people in america are
systemic victims so here is kamal harris
the vice presidential nominee of a major
party a senator from california
and a woman who according to forbes.com
has a net worth in excess of six million
dollars
talking about how black people in the
united states have never been treated as
fully human
which is weird because it seems like
kamala harris has been treated as fully
human
here is kamala harris a full human
speaking as though she has not been
treated as fully human because black
people are not treated as fully human
the reality is that the life of a black
person in america has never been treated
as fully human
and we have yet to fulfill that promise
of equal justice under law
we will only achieve that when we
finally come together
to pass meaningful police reform and
broader
criminal justice reform and acknowledge
yes acknowledge and address
systemic racism okay it's the last point
that she wants to harp on
right that when it comes to police
reform she doesn't give a damn she
doesn't i mean she didn't as a
prosecutor in california she didn't
as the attorney general of california
and she's one of the people who
filibustered tim scott's bill
to actually undergo some police reform
and she filibustered it so what she
actually cares about is we have to
acknowledge systemic racism now here's
the game
the minute that you say okay you're not
defining your term but
all right they say okay well now we
require this commitment from you a b c
d and e none of them have to do with
actually militating against inequality
none of them have to do with
effectuating greater rights for black
americans all of them have to do with
this
an explicit political agenda for the
democratic party
i'm sorry i don't trust kamala harris on
issues of what constitutes racism
considering one year ago she was calling
her running mate a racist and now she
says that was completely irrelevant
for kamala harris as with so much of the
democratic party charges of racism are
merely a tool to be used
in order to blow up obstacles in your
way namely people you don't like
and the minute they become allies well
you just forget about all of that
okay so the predictable result of all of
this is that people
are emboldened to engage in all sorts of
awful behavior because things aren't
cooling down are they
now i was informed that joe biden is so
powerful in his verbiage alone that in
his very persona he can calm the waters
after all he's proposed
zero actual effective policy when it
comes to any of this stuff he's talked
about
if not quote unquote defunding the
police shifting funds away from the
police
and towards social workers right here he
has
i love the semantic games that are
played here he the the democrats say
defund the police and then people like
that sounds like a terrible idea like
well we don't actually mean defund the
police when we say defund the police all
we mean is shift funding away from the
cops and toward other social services
and then you say okay but that sounds
like defunding the police because you're
actually taking funding away from the
police like no no
no no so why did you stay defunding the
police in the first place well that's
what we mean by defunding the police
this is all gaslighting nonsense and so
this is the the democratic party does
not have an agenda here other than to
use the the animus and the rage in the
streets
as a weapon against the american public
and say okay well if you if you want to
stop all you got to do is check on this
dotted line right here just just punch
this chad right here
and all this can end tomorrow okay so
all of this results in increased
violence around the country
seattle the violence continued to rage
last night a seattle mob actually went
to private homes last night which always
a great look the seattle mob went out to
the suburbs
and they tried to find the head of the
police union and um and they literally
marched up to people's houses
and threatened them so you can see this
tape a woman literally walking up the
front steps
to somebody's private home
really uh really classy stuff happening
here and nobody should feel threatened
after all i mean this is all just this
is all just
the best among us i've been told by
barack obama these protesters are the
best among us
okay speaking of the best among us
protesters went out to lafayette park
last night because president trump was
speaking from the lawn of the white
house and we'll get to president trump's
speech
we'll get to the legality of it it is
legal we'll get to
the the image of it and all of that
don't worry we'll get to the rnc because
all of this is the lead-up to the rnc as
i say the real rnc was not the rnc the
real rnc
was the democrats tutting violence
rioting
looting badgering and harassing
of of innocent americans in the streets
that was
that every one of these people if they
vote will be
a biden voter every single one of them
okay so
if that is the case okay if that is the
case then that was the real rnc
i said yesterday that i would just make
night four of the rnc
a live stream of what was happening in
kenosha okay you could have just live
streamed lafayette park that would have
been just as effective
we'll get to what was happening in
lafayette park in just one second
first let's talk about anti-viruses on
your computer so
right now there are these very
sophisticated viruses that are popping
up day by day that are designed to
steal your data or harm you this is why
you need pcmatic it's a next-generation
anti-virus designed to stop
modern threats like ransomware there's
an independent testing firm named av
test they just named pcmatic as the top
performer in the cyber security industry
they give it the best performance award
for 2019. only pcmatic
has american research development and
support pcmatic's competition is foreign
made
often in countries while where malware
originates pcmatic blocks annoying
malicious ads for hassle-free
web browsing they make your computer
faster and more reliable even after
years of use and they will protect
windows computers including xp vista
windows 7 8 and 10 windows servers macs
macbooks android phones and tablets
pcmatic it's just 50 bucks for five
devices for one year
with a full 30 day money back guarantee
so you can try it out see how it works
for you if you act right now
pcmatic has offered my listeners a free
month of security protection with the
purchase
of an annual license you got to protect
your data there's too many people who
are out there to steal it to access this
offer go to pcmatic.com
again to get world-class security that
keeps your computer running great go to
pcmatic.com
that is pcmatic.com the best
antivirus on the market pcmatic.com
in just a second we're going to get to
the events in lafayette park
last night because again this was the
contrast
you want the contrast you got the
contrast we'll talk about that in a
second first
it is that glorious time of the week
when i give a shout out to a daily wire
member today
it is sarah o'connor on twitter who
understands the right way to prep for
continued scholastic success
and also how to fight the terminator in
the pick sarah is getting ready to enjoy
a bowl of cereal while happily holding
the world's most elite beverage at
vessel the caption reads
starting off the new school year right
with the nutritious breakfast of
assorted grains and leftist years
courtesy of the most glorious drinking
vessel thanks daily wire for all the
work you do hashtag daily wire hashtag
left this year's tumblr hashtag
trump2020 awesome stuff keep that
routine up and i promise
you will increase your gpa well if i
can't i can't promise that at least i
promise that you will be
fortified for whatever comes next thanks
for the picture good luck with your
studies also
tonight we will be holding one of our
celebrated daily wire backstages
award-winning awards given by me last
week we covered all aspects of the dnc
both hilarious and the depressing
and then we argued for like half an hour
behind the paywall about regulations on
social media
this week we'll be recapping all the
best moments of the rnc
and i'm sure we will be talking about
the riots in the streets join me andrew
clavin michael knowles and jeremy boring
tonight at 4 pm pacific
do not miss it you're listening to the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
so the fact is that a certain number of
americans have watched the rnc over the
course of this week maybe some
15 million americans 20 million
americans
certainly not half of americans but all
americans are pretty well aware of
what's going on in the country thanks to
the interwebs the media tried to black
out the riots and the looting they've
tried to pretend for literally months on
end that this stuff has not been going
on
i'm old enough to remember when they
declared that what was happening in my
home city of los angeles was quote
unquote mostly peaceful protests while
they literally curfewed the city at 7 00
pm
every single evening and in beverly
hills at 1 pm so rioters and looters
could go around shattering windows and
threatening people
so the media tried to black it out the
democrats tried to black it out and now
it's just bursting out into the open
last night at lafayette park the
contrast could not have been more stark
the fact is that you're either standing
with the people you're about to see or
you're standing against these people
and their agenda because their agenda is
not a good agenda
okay so last night you saw people
chanting if we don't get justice
burn it down if we don't and they're
standing by the way outside saint john's
church
the church they tried to burn down these
protesters protesters
rioters and looters and we saw this
happen not that long ago
well there they were outside the church
again being like you know what if we
don't get what we want we're burning it
down
[Applause]
now you may notice that there are a lot
of people there in very very close
proximity to one another not wearing
masks this will become relevant
because later when we talk about
president trump's address on the
south lawn of the white house the media
went nuts because look at all these
terrible people who are sitting there
without masks on in close proximity yeah
so
they care about that when it's when it's
one type of person when it's another
type of person
racial justice demands that you be able
to spit in somebody else's face and give
them covet
in any case that is a secondary point
you have people literally saying they
want to burn things down if they don't
get what they want
again i don't remember any of this at
the tea party and they were called
terrorists by the media
and then we saw we saw some non-violent
violence right this was
like for example i saw a mostly peaceful
punch last night so there was a a guy
a white guy who's walking down the
street with his wife apparently these
people look like they're at the very
least in their 60s
okay and she's wearing a trump 20 20
shirt and the white guy's just walking
down the street
some young piece of crap who is
who has a bull horn and he's shouting
directly into his ear probably doing him
some sort of ear damage
there's a jacket and then out of the
blue comes a guy from behind and just
clocks from the back then mostly mostly
a peaceful punch
a mostly peaceful punch according to the
media it was a punch
but mostly peaceful is what i saw right
there also protesters held a mock
execution of
president trump so that was very
exciting stuff they'll mock execution of
president trump they brought out a
guillotine
you know it's so funny people on the
left are constantly quoting the tony
morrison line
that if they tell you who they are
believe them you might want to believe
them
here they were in lafayette park they
assembled the guillotine so it's good to
know that these people can't hold down a
job but they can't assemble a guillotine
by the way they they put one up outside
of jeff bezos's house yesterday all i
could think of is i hope jeff bezos
sends the amazon drones
ah i see you brought your 18th century
execution device welcome to 2020
that that'd been kind of great but in
any case the
they brought the guillotine into
lafayette park and they put together a
mannequin of president trump and then
beheaded it so
i'm old enough to remember when a rodeo
clown lost his job because he wore a
barack obama mask at the missouri state
fair
and the entire media were like america
is systemically racist
because a rodeo clown wore a mask of a
president by the way that rodeo client
had worn masks of other presidents as
well it didn't matter
he was fired from his job but mock
executions of trump right outside the
white house no problem
meanwhile the crowd was surrounding
secret service agents and threatening
them sounds exciting as well
they were standing right outside the
fence and they were they were really
on top of the secret service agent they
were trying to open this they could get
the secret service agent inside you can
see them crowding him
trying to prevent him from moving
[Music]
there's the crowd trying to hem him in
eventually they did get the secret
service agent inside the fence
this poor guy okay and then the
protesters started
attacking the cops as well so that was
good this is all lafayette park right
right outside the white house where
trump is speaking about law and order so
excellent juxtaposition democrats really
well done protesters
so here are some protesters getting
rowdy with the police
you can see people trying to kick the
cops people trying to fight the cops
one of my favorite aspects of this
particular type is if you continue it
long enough you'll actually see a white
lady screaming at a black officer
which is always my favorite is when you
see a karen screaming at a black officer
about systemic american racism so
lots of good stuff happening last night
in lafayette park and then
this progressed into after the after the
rnc
after trump made his speech a lot of the
people who attended that were walking
outside the white house
on the street and many of these people
are older folks
they're all dressed nicely because they
were just at the white house and you see
these pieces of human crap who are
standing outside
and flipping the bird and harassing and
getting up in the faces of elderly
people who are just walking out of the
white house trying to leave
there you see a young guy who is
screaming at people you see a young
woman running up to this this elderly
couple and screaming at them at the top
of her lungs
people being harassed and and jeered and
there you see a man
that guy's got to be what maybe 23 24.
double burning throwing a double bird to
like a seven
that lady's got to be 75 right some 75
year old woman
throwing the double bird to her really a
classy look by the way
and then you see that here's here is a
couple walking down the street
more people being
how do you harassed about the killing of
black individuals
in the united states
mr ager how do you feel about the
killing of black individuals in the
united states
how do you feel about the killing of
black individuals
in america put your hands on me again
put your hands on me again and i
you
up hands on me again and then she's
giving the left hand which is
a curious thing to do hey
all they're trying to do is get in the
hotel by the way the lady is blocked
that crazy person is blocking the door
then they're walking into the parking
lot and being harassed and screamed out
by this insane person
forget about jailing that lady jail her
parents i don't know where the hell her
parents were when she was growing up
but uh that trust fund kid that white
trust fund girl uh i have a feeling they
should have cut off that trust fund
long ago so people acting like complete
pieces of crap harassing
people who are just trying to get back
to their hotel getting in their faces
you think that's a good look
senator ramp up this this one is so
ironic i can't even express how ironic
this is so senator rand paul
and his wife are walking away from the
white house and they are surrounded by a
crowd
who attempt to assault them and the
police have to intervene and the police
have
to form kind of a barrier around a
sitting senator from kentucky
and here's what that looked like
this is the united states of america by
the way sitting senators being
surrounded
and then they hit a police officer paul
turns around tries to make sure the
police officer is okay
[Applause]
and his wife is pulling him away like
rand we gotta go here i mean this
what what a great look by the way they
were chanting at rand paul say her name
rand paul is the lead sponsor and
creator
of the justice for brianna taylor act
i'm not kidding you
because rand paul is a libertarian he
wants to ratchet down police presence
okay rand paul's justice for brianna
taylor act literally an act named after
brianna taylor
is about abolishing no knock police
raids
but they're screaming at him say her
name because they don't give a damn
these people don't give a damn they
don't give a damn about
legislation or about making the country
better or even about policy
this misnomer that they care about
making the country better in any way
has anything in the country gotten
better since the blm protest started
name the thing i keep saying this name
it i'm waiting what got better
did race relations get better do people
feel more warmly about one another do
people
feel more racial solidarity do people
feel like the problems of the united
states are being healed or are they
being exacerbated
and meanwhile the democrats said nothing
about any of this for a full week and
they let cities burn and portland burns
and seattle burns and chicago burns and
washington dc burns
i mean what in the what in the hell okay
so this was the juxtaposition
and by the way you want to know that how
you can tell that nobody gives a damn
about actually doing good or the agenda
here
and how this is just propagandistic
sloganeering nonsense
so this clip is is notable only for what
the protester keeps shouting in the face
of a sitting representative from florida
so there's a representative in brian
mast
and protesters confront brian mast and
they start screaming at him
what do you think about the police
shooting black people he says well
anytime somebody is wrongfully shot in
the united states that's bad
he said but yes but what about police
shooting black people and he says well
any time people are shot wrongfully in
the united states that's bad yes but
what about police shooting blacks
the premise is that you have to
acknowledge against all available
evidence that the police are
disproportionately shooting black people
that black people
are the victims of the american system
and that if you fail to acknowledge this
openly even if you say that you want
justice for everybody who is mistreated
in the united states that's not good
enough you have to accept
the fundamental disintegrationist
premise that america
is was and always will be a horribly
racist place until you tear down all
systems
here is uh that in a ridiculous
30-second nutshell
oh man or wrong to take anybody's rights
that's not all odds man
they haven't taken you do you feel about
police
murdering black people anybody murdered
[Music]
i don't know stephen but if they kill
him so how do you feel about a black
person that would be very specific that
would be wrong
okay so he he's literally calmly just
saying that it'd be very wrong if a
black person is murdered wrongly they're
like doesn't matter what do you say
about police shooting black because
again
the facts don't matter the stats don't
matter the only thing that matters is
the overarching narrative
a narrative that the democrats keep
backing and they cannot find a way to
thread this needle they cannot because
in order to make the case
that you ought to give them power and
they'll fix it from within the system
you also have to make the case that the
system is worth upholding and they
cannot make that system
ibram kendi has made it impossible to
make that case robin deangelo has made
it impossible to make that case either
the system is so
thoroughly corrupt it cannot be shored
up from the inside it needs to be torn
down
in which case rioting and looting are a
natural outgrowth of that program
or the system is inherently good and
worthwhile upholding
in which case your entire premise that
america is a bad place and a
systemically evil place is not true
okay and this is the problem democrats
cannot face this down they cannot or at
least they are unwilling to do so
so that brings us to the rnc last night
and the great theme of the rnc last
night was indeed that the democratic
party has been taken over by the
radicals they didn't even need to make
the case
the case was right out there in the open
right the case was was pretty clear
because all you had to do was look at
that tape from lafayette park where
innocent people who are just walking
away from a political event are being
harassed
let me note let's assume for a second
that instead of black lives matter
protesters
and writers and looters that the people
we were actually looking at were
alt-right people standing outside a
biden campaign rally harassing people as
they went outside
do you think that we might have a
conversation with every single
republican about disassociating from the
movement
every single one do you think maybe
they'd be made to answer for this sort
of stuff
and yet will it will an establishment
democrat be asked to disassociate from
this sort of stuff
will they be asked do you agree with the
black lives matter organizational agenda
will will they be asked do you believe
that the system is worth preserving when
you say that the system itself is
systemically racist
no no one will be asked this question
because of course the media believe
the same thing that many of the
protesters believe they're just arguing
at this point over
over means they are not arguing over
ends and so long as you're arguing over
means not ends
is a bolshevik versus menshevik fight
okay and that is a real problem for the
united states
it would be better if we had two parties
that actually believed in the inherent
goodness of america rather than
apparently only one party that still
cares about the inherent goodness
of the united states that was the theme
of the convention last night there's a
very clear theme
it was made clear most obviously by ann
dorn
so we've only been allowed to talk about
you want to say his name say the name
david dorn
right how many of these protesters know
the name david dorman the answer is none
okay david doran is an actual victim of
violence david dorn is an actual victim
a violent undeserved violence he is not
a person who resisted arrest and then
went to his car and reached into the car
and there was a knife on the floorboards
he is not a person who takes two police
officers
he is not a person who attempted to
resist arrest
or was in the process of committing a
crime david doran was a person
who was defending private property and
he was murdered on the streets
and no one gives two dams in the media
david dorn is not a household name
the way that any of the other household
names you know are household names his
wife
ann dorne spoke at the rnc last night
and she says i
relived the horror you need to stop
these riots we need more david dorns
that is correct this is correct and this
is this was the theme of the rnc last
night
i relived that horror in my mind every
single
day my hope is
that having you relive it with me now
will help shake this country
from this nightmare we are witnessing in
our cities
and bring about positive peaceful change
in a time when police departments are
short on resources and manpower
we need that help we should accept that
help
we must heal before we can affect change
but we cannot heal amid devastation and
chaos
president trump knows we need more
davids in our communities
not fewer i'm old enough to remember
when this is a bipartisan concern in
fact i'm old enough to remember
in my dim memory because i was 10 years
old at the time
when people like joe biden were backing
exactly the kind of stuff that andorn is
saying that we need more people like
david dorn in our communities not fewer
that the police are not the bad guys
they're the ones standing between the
bad guys and you
i'm old enough to remember when the
democratic party had sister soldier
moments
when bill clinton stood up and he said
advocation advocating racial violence is
a mistake
it's wrong it's bad to do i'm old enough
to remember that
are you if you aren't maybe you should
wonder what happened to the democratic
party such that they are having such a
damned difficult time
saying that rioting and looting are
wrong that america is actually a
fundamentally good place
now joe biden will say it in his in his
acceptance speech at the dnc
he'll say it because he'll lie to you
that that's the program of the
democratic party
just as i said last week when he covered
the dnc there was a fundamental
disconnect between what was happening at
the dnc
in the non-prime time hours what was
happening at the dnc in the prime time
hours
during the non-prime time hours they're
removing god from the pledge of
allegiance twice
during the non-prime time hours they're
urging people to kneel for the national
anthem during prime time it was joe
biden talking about how america is a
wonderful country and the constitution's
great the declaration is great and
the founding ideals are wonderful so who
do you believe who do you believe
joe biden or your own lying eyes who do
you believe
and why is it that every democratic city
that has been experiencing these riots
has allowed them to move forward if they
agree with you that america is a place
worth defending why won't they defend it
why won't they okay so the defense of
the united states was indeed the theme
of the final night of the rnc the final
night of the rnc kicked off with senate
majority leader
mitch mcconnell he suggested that the
republican party is indeed the bulwark
against the radical leftist agenda
which at this point is accurate i mean
this is the argument the argument is
that this is not about trump versus
biden it's about agenda versus agenda
it's about unionist versus
disintegrationists it's about people who
believe that the country is good
versus people who fundamentally do not
believe that the country is particularly
good or worth upholding
here is mitch mcconnell making that case
last night in his own inimitably
electrifying fashion turtley turtley
mitch mcconnell
i'm immensely proud of the work the
republican senate has done
we are the firewall against nancy
pelosi's agenda
like president trump we won't be bullied
by a liberal media
intent on destroying america's
institutions
we will stand our post on behalf of the
millions of americans whose stories
aren't told in today's newspapers whose
struggles
are just as real okay so this was again
the theme jeff van drew is a is a
democrat
is a democrat turned republican in new
jersey
and he said listen joe biden that guy is
run by the radicals you may think that
he is some sort of
wall against the radical wing of the
party can you show a shred of evidence
to that effect
when the democrats tried to order me
around
i was ready willing and able to say
i've had enough with their radical
socialist
agenda do you really believe joe biden
is ready
willing and most of all able to do the
same
as joe says come on man
joe biden is being told what to do by
the radicals running my former party
the same radicals trying to install him
as their puppet president
okay so this is the theme rudy giuliani
spoke so rudy did not in fact speak
about ukraine or
impeachment or anything like that he
focused in on what he was best at which
was stopping crime in new york city the
reason that rudy giuliani was considered
america's mayor was not just because of
9 11
it's because you took a city in complete
disarray in the early 1990s
and turned times square from basically a
cd hot spot where you picked up
prostitutes
into disneyland in the middle of new
york city he took it from one of the
least safe cities in the united states
one of the most safe cities in the
united states and he says listen
don't let democrats do for the country
what they're currently doing to all of
america's major cities
new yorkers wonder how did we get
overwhelmed by crime
so quickly and declined so fast
don't let democrats do to america what
they have done to new york
it is clear that a vote for biden and
the democrats
creates the risk that you will bring
this lawlessness
to your city to your town to your suburb
okay and he is not wrong about this
there is tape from seattle people going
into the suburbs there was tape from
kenosha of people talking about walking
into the suburbs
okay this is this is ugly ugly stuff and
the republicans are right to harp on it
dana white who's the head of the ufc he
spoke at the 2016 convention for trump
he's friends with trump
he spoke again in 2020 he said you got
to stop demeaning the police the police
are in fact the solution to this problem
they are not the problem
it blows my mind how quickly some of the
leadership in this country
has forgotten the critical role first
responders play
in our society police departments and
other law enforcement
even some fire departments have faced
opposition from many in this country
but they are always the people who are
asked to step
up when things are at their worst and
put themselves at risk
that has certainly been the case during
this ongoing pandemic
come on america defunding these vital
positions
is not the answer okay this is
again this was this is one of the big
themes now this was balanced out by the
fact that president trump while
proclaiming law and order
has been quite sympathetic to people who
are trying to make their lives better
after having committed crimes ready
signed into justice criminal justice
reform now
i've had problems with criminal justice
reform because i think that there are
elements of it that soften sentences for
criminals
and frankly i think that if you're a
criminal mostly you belong in prison
there are some people who make the best
of their lives
one of those people however was alice
marie johnson she gave a very powerful
speech last night
in which you know trump pardoned her and
then he signed into law the criminal
justice reform bill alice johnson spoke
at the at the rnc last night and she
pointed out that under joe biden's bill
she went to jail
and donald trump saw her as a human
being who had decided to make the best
of her life
when president trump heard about me
about the
injustice of my story he saw me
as a person he had compassion
and he acted free
embodied thanks to president trump
but free in mind thanks to the almighty
god
i couldn't believe it i always
remembered that god
knew my name even in my darkest hour
but i never thought a president would
okay so all this was very good stuff at
the rnc last night for president trump
tom cotton
played attack dog last night against joe
biden he says you know while
democrats are encouraging people to take
a knee for america it's not time to take
a knee for america's time to stand up
for america and pledge allegiance to
america again this is a message that
republicans should be hammering on
china's not giving up in fact they're
rooting for joe biden
america's other enemies won't give up
either
but joe biden would be as wrong and weak
over the next four years as he has been
for the last
50. we need a president who stands up
for america not one who takes a knee
a strong and proud america is a safe
america
safe from our enemies and safe from war
okay so this is the overall message of
the rnc over the last
four nights right touting some of the
stuff that trump has done on the record
pushing on the notion that the democrats
have backed again a narrative that
really tears the country
apart so how the media responded to all
this so there were two big media
narratives last night as all this was
unfolding
one big media narrative is that donald
trump is a bad man because he spoke from
the white house so valerie jarrett the
former chief of staff to
barack obama she tweeted out that she
was very upset that the white house has
never before been used as a political
prop during a convention
it belongs to all of the american people
not just those who support one party oh
it's never been used as a political prop
has it
i'm old enough to remember when barack
obama lit the white house up with a gay
pride flag
after the obergefell decision i'm old
enough to remember when barack obama
used the white house to film all sorts
of campaign videos
i mean i'm old enough to remember in
fact
when barack obama turned the white house
into a place where he could watch his
favorite musicians perform their
favorite concerts
i'm sorry the the sort of new pearl
clutching propriety at the uses of the
white house for political purposes
i may not love it it is legal the white
house the
office of government ethics was asked
specifically whether trump could speak
on the south lawn
the south lawn is not technically a
government building because it's a lawn
and so they said yes he can use it it is
worth noting
that ronald reagan announced his
re-election bid
from the oval office that jimmy carter
announced his re-election bid from the
east room of the white house
that fdr accepted his nomination in 1940
for the democratic party
from the white house so there is in fact
precedent for this is the middle of a
global pandemic makes it kind of
difficult
to assemble a crowd at a major at a
major place so narrative number one was
very very bad that trump spoke from
the white house and you're right if a
democrat did it i'd be kind of pissed
and trump did it i don't think it's
wonderful i think trump could have
figured out a thousand ways to do this
differently
is this going to lose trump any votes
the pearl clutching from people who are
poo pooing actual riots in america's
major cities also the media were very
very upset at the lack of social
distancing
so the media play this wonderful
wonderful game where social distancing
is super important so long as you're a
conservative or a church-goer or a
person who wants to go to school or go
to your work
social distancing is really really
important mascoring is super important
if however you're out in the streets
screaming at a police officer
totally fine so now this which is the
leftist news source they tweeted out
about 1500 people were invited to the
white house to watch president trump's
gop convention speech
masks were not required chairs were
placed inches apart and there was no
social distancing hashtag rnc
okay so first of all worth noting it's
outdoors second of all the selective
outrage with regards to masking and
social distancing is pretty astonishing
is it not
i mean the selective outrage is so over
the top how do i know
here's the headline today from the
washington post march on washington
updates
thousands gather at lincoln memorial to
march for racial equality
march on washington organizers expect 50
000 people to gather in washington on
friday to call for criminal justice
reform and racial equity
and to honor the 57th anniversary of
reverend of reverend martin luther king
jrs i have a dream address from the same
spot
organizers began planning in june after
the funeral of george floyd they
recently lowered their crowd estimates
citing fewer buses arriving in the city
because of covid they plan to highlight
the civil rights issues of today and
bring well-known speakers to address the
crowd while also mitigating the spread
of the novel coronavirus with strict
safety protocols yes i am sure i am sure
the march w get off your get your knee
off our next march on washington
it's a little bit unwieldy we'll begin
with speeches from the steps of the
lincoln memorial followed by a
choreographed march the martin luther
king jr memorial in west potomac park
the event is expected to end
around 3 p.m by the way there are
already pictures emerging a lot of
people are not actually wearing masks a
lot of people are grouped closely
together
just like they were last night in the
middle of these lafayette park protests
the media have nothing to say about that
sort of stuff so you know they're
clutching at straws and they're looking
for a counter narrative
when the best they can do is that by the
way the best attempt at a counter
narrative
was a woman named andrea bernstein from
wnyc and propublica
last night ivanka ivanka trump spoke at
the rnc and it was well eh
i mean ivanka trump is fine i don't know
that she had anything special to say
other than trump as her dad
but ivanka at one point was talking
about her three-year-old daughter
making a lego model of the white house
here is what andrea bernstein tweeted
quote
ivanka trump has tweeted a photo of her
son joseph sorry it's her son
three-year-old with his grandfather at
the resolute desk
with the lego white house i've asked the
white house if three-year-old joseph
indeed built it of his own initiative
and if he had assistance
we'll tweet reply if when i get it
wow i mean that is some intrepid
woodward and bernstein level journalism
right there
did the three-year-old build the lego
white house of his own initiative
wow they're on top of it guys so the
counter narrative
this morning are not enough social
distancing at the white house
also bad for trump to use the white
house as a backdrop also
did ivanka's three-year-old son build
his own lego white house
slow clap for our intrepid media slow
clap for these people
who continue to maintain without
evidence that what happened in kenosha
in the shooting was a white supremacist
who went there for blood
that cops are routinely out there waking
up in the morning and killing black
people
and that all of this is donald trump's
fault really
these reporters they are so good at what
they do okay so all of this brings us to
trump's actual speech
and so now finally i know we're going a
bit long here but a lot of news
president trump gives his final rnc
acceptance speech the thing was way too
long okay like it just ended five
minutes ago i thought he was actually
going to segway
from his rnc accept nomination
acceptance speech directly into a second
inaugural i mean that's how long this
thing was taking i believe it was now
the officially the longest
single acceptance speech in the history
of in the modern history of acceptance
speeches
says way too long buried in a 70 minute
speech 70 minutes
i understand they were trying to show
that he's vigorous and you can go 70
minutes well
joe biden could barely stand upright for
24. i get it but you didn't need to do
it 70 minutes
that's a that's a long time i mean
that's like the lord of the rings cycle
well the the the speech was too long
buried in a 70 minute speech was about
25 minutes of an excellent speech
and then there was this long litany of
stuff that he done and things that he
was going to do and it sounded more like
a state of the union frankly
than like an acceptance speech which is
supposed to be crystallized and
condensed
and drawing the contrast that stuff was
in there it was buried in a bunch of
other stuff so it's like
a wagnerian opera it was three hours and
it could have been an hour and a half
but in any case trump did say many of
the things that needed to be said he
said most of them in the first five
minutes which is the part that really
matters
and again most people didn't watch the
entire thing live people will watch
clips of it so
president trump led off by again talking
about pride and country
which is something that democrats simply
cannot talk about these days because
they keep talking about how america
is a horrible evil place and always
unless they're running the place it's
horrible and evil
always so here's trump talking about
patriotism in the united states
we will rekindle new faith in our values
new pride in our history and a new
spirit of unity that can only be
realized through love
for our great country because we
understand that america is not a land
cloaked in darkness
america is the torch that enlightens the
entire world
that's a beautiful line one of the
problems for trump is always the
teleprompter trump is less energetic
than rally trump but you know what
better he should stay on teleprompter
for the rest of this campaign if trump
just stays on teleprompter the rest of
this campaign i think he will be
re-elected
if he gets off teleprompter and starts
tweeting random crap tomorrow then um
obviously all the good work done by the
rnc will be undone pretty quickly
trump talked about covet he he point and
then he made a pledge which
yeah the media were immediately freaking
out because trump basically said we're
developing a vaccine
and maybe we'll produce a vaccine before
the end of the year maybe even sooner so
they're saying he's gonna october
surprise this thing
he's first of all if he did wouldn't
that be like the best thing ever forget
politically
aren't you rooting for there to be a
vaccine ready yesterday here is trump
making this pledge and then the media
being like he's gonna
he's gonna rush a vaccine out there and
and and that would be bad because then
he might win
oh my god here is trump in recent months
our nation
and the entire planet has been struck by
a new
and powerful invisible enemy
like those brave americans before us we
are meeting this challenge
we are delivering life-saving therapies
and will produce a vaccine before the
end of the year
or maybe even sooner okay so
the media freaked out about this and
then he started in with the real
contrast
between the two parties and this was the
the key section of his speech
frankly i think his speech writers if
they haven't read the book they
certainly listen to the show because
when i talk about the
contrast between a unionist vision of
the united states and our history
and the disintegrationist vision of the
united states and and
her history that's what trump was
talking about here was trump talking
about what drew america together what
makes america unique
what united generations passed was an
unshakable confidence
in america's destiny and an unbreakable
faith
in the american people they knew that
our country is blessed by god
and has a special purpose in this world
it is that conviction that inspired the
formation of our union
our westward expansion
the abolition of slavery the passage of
civil rights
the space program and the overthrow of
fascism tyranny and communism
this towering american spirit has
prevailed over every challenge
and lifted us to the summit of human
endeavor and yet despite all of our
greatness as a nation everything
we have achieved is now in danger that
is absolutely correct obviously and then
he goes on he
explicitly spells out the choice he says
this is really about the visions of
america and you're gonna have to pick
at no time before have voters faced a
clearer choice between two parties
two visions two philosophies
or two agendas this election will decide
whether we save the american dream
or whether we allow a socialist agenda
to demolish our
cherished destiny i mean
again correct and then he got into
what's happening in the streets and
this is the the chief issue because all
of these philosophical breaks
have broken out into violence in the
streets right the people who are
marching and
the people who are rioting and looting
they are all 16 19 project believers
they believe in the narrative that is
the narrative they believe
and meanwhile the democratic party is
saying we ought to give them space we
have to let them do what they want to do
here was trump saying
listen this is either going to be a law
abiding country that believes in itself
ordained
your vote will decide whether we protect
law-abiding americans
or whether we give free rein to violent
anarchists
and agitators and criminals who
threaten our citizens
and this election will decide whether we
will defend the american way of life or
whether we will allow a
radical movement to completely dismantle
and destroy it
that won't happen okay he continued
along these lines he says listen
at the dnc they told you exactly what
they believe so you should probably
believe them
here's what the here's what he said
about the dnc and biden specifically he
named check biden 41 times right so
clearly biden never mentioned trump
because the entire dnc was about from so
he never had to be named he's like
voldemort he never had to say his name
trump was trying to make the issue biden
but really more than buying the entire
dnc
here he says exactly what he means about
biden's agenda
at the democrat national convention joe
biden and his party repeatedly assailed
america as a land of racial economic
and social injustice
so tonight i ask you a simple question
how can the democrat party ask to lead
our country
when it spends so much time tearing down
great line great line and true how do
you expect to lead the country when you
say that the country is bad so you say
give us control of the system so we can
tear down the system
but also if you're trying to tear down
the system from the outside you're bad
yeah good luck with that
good luck then trump explicates this he
says there's a difference of visions and
what america means
in the left's backward view they do not
see america as the most free
just and exceptional nation on earth
instead they see a wicked nation that
must be punished
for its sins our opponents say that
redemption for you can only come
from giving power to them this is a
tired anthem spoken by every repressive
movement
throughout history but in this country
we don't look to
career politicians for salvation in
america we don't turn to government
to restore our souls we put our faith in
almighty god
hey this is a great line again buried in
a 70 minute speech there was some really
really really good stuff okay then he
went into a litany of all the things
biden has done wrong over his career
from being friendly to china to being
wrong on nearly every
foreign policy issue of our time and
then he got to the the main point about
joe biden which is that biden is just a
stand-in for the democratic agenda this
is trump clip 12.
is biden biden as a as a trojan horse
for socialism a case that i've been
making pretty regularly
biden is a trojan horse for socialism if
joe biden doesn't have the strength
to stand up to wild-eyed
marxists like bernie sanders and his
fellow radicals and there are many
there are many many we see them all the
time it's incredible actually
then how is he ever going to stand up
for you
he's not okay that is exactly right okay
so a couple more clips of trump here so
trump 15. he he points out i mean this
is such a
gaping hole for the democrats they went
through their entire convention without
mentioning rioting and looting and
violence in america cities once because
these are all
democratic cities they are all
democratic cities here is trump
bringing this up very awkward stuff for
the democrats so they're focusing in on
ivanka trump's son's lego set
during their convention joe biden and
his supporters
remain completely silent about the
rioters and criminals
spreading mayhem in democrat-run cities
they never
even mentioned it during their entire
convention never once mentioned
now they're starting to mention it
because their poll numbers are going
down like a rocking water
it's too late joe in the face of
left-wing anarchy and mayhem
in minneapolis chicago and other cities
joe biden's campaign did not condemn it
they donated to it at least 13 members
of joe biden's campaign staff donated
to a fund to bail out vandals arsonists
anarchists looters and rioters from jail
actually correct that is technically
correct okay and this is sort of his
final and best line
trump said listen if the democrats want
to stand with these people
they can but i'm not going to
if the democrat party wants to stand
with anarchists
agitators rioters looters and flag
burners
that is up to them but i as your
president
will not be a part of it the republican
party will remain the voice
of the patriotic heroes who keep america
safe
and salute the american flag if he stays
on this message he's going to win
if he gets off this message he's going
to lose it's really that simple okay the
convention concluded with this big
fireworks show so bite into this kind of
tiny little fireworks show
uh in delaware and trump everything is
bigger and better and and glitzier and
ritzier
so he did this big firework show around
the washington monument
and the fireworks actually spelled out
trump 2020
which is really trumpy i mean that is
super trumpy it's a big giant gold t
appearing in the sky now this also
prompted there were pictures last night
of the rioters and the and the
protesters
who are standing there flipping off the
fireworks because fireworks are also
systemically racist
alrighty well you now have your contrast
so now you get to decide
which america do you want and we will
see whether trump can maintain that
message
going forward okay we'll be back here
later today with two additional hours of
content also tonight we're doing a
backstage so we'll be discussing
everything rnc and riot related so stick
around for that
you're listening to the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas our technical director is
austin stevens
executive producer jeremy boring our
supervising producers are mathis glover
and robert sterling
assistant director pava wiedowsky our
associate producer is nick chien
the show is edited by adam syavets audio
mix by mike caromina hair and makeup is
by nika geneva
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2020.
you know the matte wall show it's not
just another show about about politics i
think there are enough of those
already out there we talk about culture
because culture drives
politics and it drives everything else
so my main focuses are
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about i
hope you'll give it a listen
you